so you think it's possible that the
universe
is full of bacteria and even those stars
that last a thousand times longer than
the Sun
even even on the
planets that orbit those
Stars
maybe it's bacteria
and four billions and billions and
billions of years we actually don't know
what triggered the evolution to
complexity on Earth that's still a big
question mark is that the most
impressive invention on Earth to you
that Cambrian Revolution is really what
took us towards what we are and in the
meantime there were the dinosaurs Etc
the dinosaurs were wiped out so the
evolution could have taken a completely
different turn it's always I would say
mass extinction that are going to drive
what's the end game but
um
yeah you take two planets and you change
you know those asteroid impacts all
those big geological events that wipe
out like 90 of Life at any time
the thing that seemed to be
um interesting there are two things the
first one is where you are located on
our galaxy uh matters a lot
we actually are in the habitable zone of
our galaxy
and if you are too close to the center
then it's a lot denser and remember we
have the Oort cloud around our solar
system and if you are in the region of
the Galaxy that's too populated then you
are going to run interaction
gravitational interaction with all these
stars and since it's more dense you will
have more of the Comets that are living
in the old Cloud being ejected from the
Oort cloud and coming towards the inner
solar system and collide with planets so
you will have more of these impacts if
you are too close to the center of the
Galaxy not to mention the radiation
there is a place in our galaxy where
it's a really bad neighborhood you don't
want to be there you wouldn't be able to
have life but what really matters is
extinctions but also
um the climate history
of a planet has a role to play and it
seems that
it's a theory it still has to be backed
up by more observation but there is a
good correlation
between not only the passage of the
solar system towards the center of the
Galaxy there is one place where we get
hit by asteroid because of the
interaction I was telling you about but
the other one is the climate with the
minankovic Cycles big jumps in life's
Evolution seem to be associated with
snowball Earth episodes
we don't know why yet
snowball episode
intuitively you would think that they
are connected to a decrease in life
because the whole earth is covered in
ice
but for some reason they wear big jumps
in evolution right after
each of those episodes
and and today there are other things
like why all of a sudden you have
mutation that seems to be responsible
for you know a big jump in evolution we
are not clear yet so all of those things
when you're thinking about life
elsewhere are going to come into play
and I cannot tell you that a planet that
remains habitable for much longer than
the earth will have an evolutionary path
that's the same or different depends on
extension depends on climate depends on
but not it's a little bit surreal there
were two descendants of apes
figure out what what the heck is going
on and I mean we're very biased even as
a so you uh we're biased as humans
you're less biased as a scientist uh but
we still love Earth we still don't know
anything but this Earth and so even
though you tried to get escape from
thinking of what life is in the search
for the nature of life we still kind of
connected to the way we understand the
nature of life here on Earth so
I think that it's a little different
than that we are biased when it comes to
the origin of Life yes because
well we are the only model we know and
as I said it makes sense because it
seems that a lot of you know uh stars
like the sun appear till billion years
ago and there are lots of words that
really resemble the Earth and lots of
water out there and lots of condition
that could be a repeat of what we know
and we know that this biochemistry works
so as a again as I mentioned what is
going to change is really the evolution
of a planet Extinction geology Etc but
our model is probably very abundant I'm
not saying that the end game is going to
resemble us because of all this
extensions Etc but this is a good bias
it's one that has the number for it you
know the principle of mediocrity I I
think that in that case
it really applies where the Earth is
representative
of an abundance of other words
now of course there can be other
biochemistry we have some examples in
our own solar system Titan might be a
representative of that we are not very
clear of the kind of biochemistry that
can come out of a world where you have
hydrocarbon likes and rains and and
things like that but we are going there
so we will learn something about this
um so the bias is right there the nature
of life is different
if really life is the best way the
universe has to fight entropy
there is no bias there because physics
is the same all across the universe at
least the universe we know there might
be other universes but the one we know
works with the same physics so if life
is the the best way to fight entropy
you can imagine that life permeates
the entire universe and then the
question might change to like flavors of
ice cream what are the flavors of
complexity that this process this nature
of Life leads to and there we might have
bias about what complexity looks like
what beautiful complexity looks like
we'll look at humans that operate a
certain physical scale and uh time scale
and we think this is intelligence we
have another problem we don't know what
life is we don't know what intelligence
is and we don't know what Consciousness
is but we are trying to tackle the big
question but do you know what complexity
is also you know no I I think that we
have to be honest and as a scientist and
I'm going to step back and talk about
intelligence uh for me bacteria
that has survived like cyanobacteria
that has survived just like us
four billion years in one Incarnation or
another and actually they are very
similar to the one that they wear 3.5
billion years ago it has some
intelligence about its environment
so for complexity it might be
that we need to take the world literally
which is an assemblage or additional
capacity to gather collect store
information maybe this is something like
that or actually use that information to
do something with it
but I do completely agree with you when
you talk about flavor of ice cream I
think this is exactly it and
I have a basic education about what
physics is doing right now
and I'm look at quantum physics and what
it says about the universe and about the
connection about an atom here and an
atom hair a photon here in the Forum
there and I am starting to put Maybe
wrongfully two and two together but in
my mind
and of course it's nothing until I can
prove it but in my mind the universe is
connected everywhere
in all different places so this life
connection is something that as you said
pyramid the universe and the way to find
life
might be very different than to look for
the origins of life I think it's a good
thing to go out there and look for the
original by somewhere else because it's
the manifestation of the nature of life
that's all of a sudden becomes
apparent evident to our eye but
what I think
would be our greatest achievement is
that if we can find that process of life
because at that point in my mind the
universal is sudden is going to
illuminate itself with actually
it's living Force what I can only call a
living Force to me this is what we are
looking at a universe that becomes more
and more complex with time more and more
able to gather information and
interestingly enough why
to understand itself so Sagan was right
when he was selling we are the universe
trying to understand itself
and the more we go the more the universe
become alive
maybe intelligent and maybe also
conscious